[Music]
all right before I get to what's going
on in the world this week I want to once
again thank all of you who support what
we do here on the Rubin report I'm
thrilled to finally be able to show you
our brand new home studio today it took
a tremendous amount of blood sweat tears
and yeah even money to build it and we
simply could not have done it without
you
of course the main thanks goes out to
all of you who donate monthly to the
show on patreon as you guys give us the
budget to create content as we see fit
with no executives bosses or middlemen
between me and you beyond our patrons I
also want to thank all of those who have
given one-time donations on PayPal as
well as to all of you who watch like
comment on and share our videos with our
new home studio we can fully expand on
everything we've been building here
including more shows long our interviews
and new segments I truly believe that
the ideas of classical liberalism logic
reason an individual liberty are the
only solution to the authoritarian and
extremist problems we're seeing all over
the world right now I'll continue to
have conversations with people i both
agree with and disagree with and just as
importantly i'll continue to listen to
you from my patreon one-on-one chats to
group google hangouts to emails and yeah
even twitter you guys consistently
amazed me at your insight and desire for
truth my commute is now just 10 steps
down the hall from my bedroom and I
promise to use that newfound time to
make this show even better than before
you've truly helped my dreams become a
reality and somehow we're right back at
the beginning in the course of the month
that we were building this studio
basically a million things happened I'm
not sure if you heard about this but we
had an election in the United States and
Donald Trump yeah Donald Trump is now
the president-elect while most of the
media seem to be completely blindsided
by the result I can honestly say that I
wasn't I talked to and listened to
people like Scott Adams Miley innopolis
and Mike Serna vich and whether I agreed
with them or not I realized that there
was a real political movement behind
their words when you couple this reality
with moderate liberals and moderate
conservatives who are sick of identity
takes an outrage culture Trump winning
actually seems kind of obvious in
hindsight I'm trying to do my best not
to judge Trump's actions until he's
actually in office because until then
everything people are saying are just
guesses and conjecture as I said in my
direct message right after the election
I'll be the first to hold Trump speak to
the fire once he's in office but the
simple fact is that he's the
president-elect now and we've got to
give him a chance that's the rub of
democracy your team doesn't always win
but you can't burn down the system just
because you were on the losing end this
time regardless of whether you hate or
love Trump there's no doubt that
something good did come out of this
election people seem to be engaged in a
whole new way people are talking
politics fighting for what they believe
and getting involved in the conversation
maybe even more now than when Obama ran
for the first time back in 2008 I think
we're gonna get a whole new crop of
political leaders out of this chaos and
I hope some new political movements as
well as I've been saying for a year now
if you're an old-school liberal then an
old-school conservative is no longer
your enemy I really think a new center
can arise from this and if Trump is
smart he can actually make that happen
Trump is a populist and that means he
wants to be popular most of us are
socially liberal and fiscally
conservative most of us are not the
alt-right or the regressive left most of
us don't care what you do in the privacy
of your own home and we want government
to take less instead of giving more I
think we can actually push Trump towards
these ideals but if not then maybe we'll
just have to create our own movement to
do so actually maybe that's already
begun with all this in mind I've got the
perfect guess for you this week radio
host and columnist ben shapiro ben is
what I would consider an old-school
conservative witch like me as a
classical liberal is a strange place to
be these days does he fit in with the
new Trump led Republican Party anymore
than I fit in with the identity politics
driven Democratic Party not so sure
we're both on the outside looking in and
that's exactly where I think we can
start building bridges
I was on The Daily wire livestream with
Ben on election night and I got to see
as he was alternately thrilled that
Hillary lost but also totally dismayed
that Trump had won a couple hours and a
few beers later we both managed to
survive the evening even if we didn't
see eye to eye on the whole thing there
is huge opportunity for all of us to
shape the future of the country right
now but there's no way it can change if
we just complain about the system
instead of getting involved the rhetoric
on Russia fake news stories about fake
news and outrage after outrage are not
only gonna keep coming but they're gonna
get stronger and stronger the only way
we'll stop them and cut through the
noise is to figure out what we believe
and to fight for it I've got a new
studio and a new commitment to continue
that fight and I hope that you'll join
me
[Music]
you
[Music]